my name's Forrest Gump people call me
for was gone this weekend Forrest Gump
was released in IMAX for its 20th
anniversary 20th anniversary what is
happening I watch this when I was a kid
and I thought rather than seeing the one
film that opens a new wide release this
weekend the identical starring some kind
of Elvis Presley guy I'd see another
film that stars someone playing Elvis
Presley Forrest Gump is an incredible
movie directed by Robert Zemeckis
starring Tom Hanks it won him an Academy
Award for Best Actor for the second year
in a row after Philadelphia it also won
Best Picture Forrest Gump is a movie
that came out in 1994 and it was also
competing with movies like pulp fiction
and Shawshank Redemption should it have
won over those movies I don't know about
that is it a good movie
absolutely Forrest Gump is an incredible
movie it's such a well written film
about a guy who's not exactly the
smartest guy in the world and yet
despite his lower intelligence he's able
to conquer that by accidentally being
involved with some of the biggest world
events of the 20th century and he's a
damn good ping-pong player can't take a
picture though movie starts out when
he's younger he has his leg braces on
he's running away from some bullies and
you get that famous scene where his leg
braces shatter and then you get that
line that everyone when I grew up said
no matter what even if your name wasn't
Forrest I heard that line everywhere if
you were running and people happen to be
watching you run inevitably someone
would shout that it just happened all
the time but if the central story of
this movie is his gigantic crush on
Jenny played by Robin Wright he's known
her since she was a little girl she was
his first real friend and throughout the
entire movie he's constantly thinking
about Jenny I'm not a smart man but I
know what love is what this movie does
so beautifully is we've so many
different time periods and events
perfectly through narration which is
oftentimes frowned upon in movies like
Oh narration that's an easy way out of
explaining stories but I actually really
like narration when it's done really
well like American Psycho or Forrest
Gump now if you've seen Tropic Thunder
you've seen Robert
Jr's speech yeah Tom Hanks Forrest Gump
slow yes retarded maybe braces on his
live but he charmed the pants off Nixon
anyone a ping-pong competition that
ain't retarded he was goddamn war hero
we know any retarded war heroes
everybody knows you never go full retard
if Tom Hanks had just gone a little bit
farther into that this entire movie
would have failed but he had the perfect
line of knowing exactly how far to go
with his performance and not making
himself out to be an idiot and this
movie really champions the idea if
someone can make a difference no matter
what their intelligence level is or what
their social standing is it doesn't
matter any of that stuff whatever you
want to do with your life you can do it
and Forrest Gump really supports that
idea because it has a character who
doesn't even really approach life from
the average human standpoint like well I
gotta do this I gotta do that with my
life I have to do this is my life he
just does things he goes to the Vietnam
War because someone hands him a flier
and suggests sit he starts running for
years because he just felt like it I
mean all the things that he does in this
movie that inspired a whole bunch of
different people is simply because he
felt like it so maybe we should all just
do whatever we want that's probably a
bad idea don't do that Robin Wright is
also really good in this movie because
she could be a character that you grow
to hate the girl who constantly denies
Forrest all the time but you understand
her because it's able to portray the
time period in which her character is
living so well as well as her difficult
childhood so it's really well written in
that regard as well because it has all
these characters and it's able to make
the perfect balance of how you feel for
each one of them and care for each one
of them without any of them getting
annoying especially Forrest Gump I mean
this character is really a gamble he
could be terrible but Tom Hanks and the
writers and Robert Zemeckis just found
the exact right line they needed to be
on Lieutenant Dan Gary Sinise is awesome
in this movie where is he been he's been
on that CSI New York show I guess for a
while but I mean come on man can make
the movies you're awesome
but what Forrest Gump does so well is
make a perfect blend of humor drama
emotion like really hardcore emotion
like this movie does make you cry at a
few parts and it's because you're with
this guy throughout his whole life and
you're able to see a life that is filled
with humor that just so happened to
experience all of America's most
important events over the past few years
and it's all done seamlessly blended
with really impressive CGI which is not
something
movie gets enough credit for this movie
was actually fairly revolutionary with a
lot of different CGI techniques Forrest
Gump is a fantastic movie if you guys
have a IMAX theater near you definitely
go check it out because it is being
released right now I'm gonna give
Forrest Gump an A+ I really hope this
year has a new release that I can give
an A+ to because I haven't given an A+
to a new release of 2014 yet I'm still
waiting for that perfect movie I'm still
waiting also I want to let you guys know
that audible.com is continuing to
sponsor my videos thanks to you guys for
checking out their downloads and thanks
to them for doing that for me if you go
to audible.com slash Chris you can get a
free audio book of your choice I've
downloaded Stephen King's carry a lot of
his books are on there because he is my
favorite author if you go to audible.com
slash Chris you can get a free audiobook
download of your choice because they are
kind enough to sponsor my videos and I
thank them so very much for doing that
and I thank you guys also for visiting
that link and checking them out I had
somebody email me and thanked me because
they needed an audio book for their
school course they couldn't afford it
and because of me they got it for free
so thanks to audible for allowing that
to happen and I hope you guys do check
out audible.com slash Kris and get a
free download of an audio book of your
choice guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
you